welcome everyone
today we have the pleasure of having
professor andres moya from the economics
department at universidad los angeles
and who is a visiting fellow at the
david rockefeller center for latin
american studies at harvard university
professor moya will be talking today
about promoting mental health and early
childhood development in colombia
professor moya research focuses on the
economic psychological and behavioral
consequences of violence and forced
displacement in colombia in particular
professor moya has analyzed the effect
of violence and psychological trauma on
economic behavior human capital
accumulation and performance in the
labor market
so professor moya the floor is yours
thanks
so so thank you so much thank you for
the opportunity to present here um i'm
going to be presenting
the impact evaluation results of this
program called semi del giapego which
roughly translates as seeds for
attachment
and it's a project that uh it's a joint
endeavor between psychologists at uh the
university of california san francisco
an economist at the university of los
angeles where i'm based
and the whole idea of this of this
project is to promote maternal mental
health
and early childhood development in
conflict affected communities so i'm
going to be presenting the results for
the rct that we implemented in colombia
and maybe just to start with a little
bit of the motivation for this talk
uh right now and this is probably
something that people here know very
well
right now over two billion people are
living in conflict affected settings
among these uh populations so children
have been disproportionately affected
450 million
uh children globally around 20 of
children in the world
live and are born in these settings
and we have also witnessed the increase
in displacement of both refugee flows
internal displacement in the past
decades
right now by the end of 2021 we had 82
million displaced persons including 35
million children
and of course right now we're actually
witnessing very sadly the
increase in
displacement in refugee flows in the
ukraine
what we know is that the exposure to
conflict and displacement can have very
long lasting consequences across
different dimensions
it can take a toll on mental health
it can actually affect chronic poverty
you can trust thresh the populations
into
both
economic social and psychological
poverty traps
and we know from previous research that
it can
hinder and affect early childhood
development
and that by doing so it can affect the
last trajectories of many of these
children so of course when we think
about the magnitude of these uh of these
problems and the magnitude of the
conflicts across the globe
there's a main question in terms of how
can we protect children
and how can we prevent the
intergenerational transmission of trauma
and poverty in these comfort affected
settings so this is the broad motivation
that we will be working
and we know at least when we dig into
the literature about the childhood
development
we know that children need nurturing
stimulation relationship with the with
an adult
for property child development
we know that these type of relationships
are actually important for children to
be able to process
the stress
that arises and maybe everyday seconds
so these nurturing and in caring
relationships can actually buffer the
psychological effects of stress
and these are effects that uh occur at
both a neuronal and biological levels to
know not only a behavioral effect
and based on this we also note that
toxic stress
emerges when children are exposed to
severe and systematic adversities
and when the adults are not available to
provide these nurturing relationships
so what happens with such a stress is
that the biological stress response
systems of the children are being
passively activated
think of children that has been
experimenting uh displacement poverty
exclusion it's being bombarded by
different adversities that are going to
trigger this
biological stress response system
and when the child doesn't uh
receive that proper nurturing and caring
registered brought up by the by the
parent
this stress response is going to be
constantly activated and
pretty much in an overload
and this is going to have very negative
effects on child's uh brain architecture
the number of connections at the near
the neurons the strength of the urinal
connections and it's also going to
affect your physical and mental health
and it's going to have very life
altering effects right
and so the key question here is how to
promote these nurturing relationships in
context of conflict and force
displacement
and when we think about our project we
take a step back and we think about the
binding constraint
so the binding constraint here is the
capacity of caregivers to build these
nurturing relationships
and we consider that these uh
these capacities are not exogenous
they're actually endogenous to the
context of conflict
conflict and displacement actually have
negative consequences on
caregivers mental health
um parents who are struggling with the
with trying to understand displacement
trying to cope with the shock of
conflict are actually going to be have
less
emotional resources available to be able
to understand what's happening at the
same time to connect with the children
in colombia we know for instance that
the incidence of at-risk symptoms of
anxiety and depression
are three to four times greater in
conflict affected regions than in other
regions not affected by conflict
and we know that this uh the severity of
this uh psychological problems are gonna
drain the emotional resources of
caregivers
and this is gonna tender their capacity
to be emotionally available for children
right so so again children are being
affected by the stress
that characterizes these
conflict-affected settings these
settings of conflict and force
displacement but at the time their
caregivers are also being affected and
this is going to drain their capacity to
uh
better connect
in a nurturing and caring relationships
with their children
and so this creates this
this concern for the toxic stress and
the lifelong consequences that it's
going to have on children
so what we do and and that says this is
the purpose of this talk because we
developed this program called samida
zapago again it roughly translates this
seeds with attachment
and it's a community based like a social
model for caregivers of young children
who have also been affected by confident
displacement
and in developing the the program we
take a step back
and we again recognize this binding
constraint but the capacity of
caregivers to provide these nurturing
and care relationships is not exogenous
it's being affected at the same time
by conflict and displacement
so we recognize that if we want to
protect children and if we want to
enhance these uh nurturing caring
relationships we need to take a step
back and think about the emotional
resources of of the caregivers and we
need to think about the mature amount of
health in general
so the objective of the program is to
promote maternal mental health as an
outcome itself a development outcome
that's very important by itself but also
it's going to be important because it's
a vehicle for us to promote healthy
child parent relationships and then to
protect early childhood
we implemented this program in a setting
of active conflict we're going to be
working and i'm going to tell you a
little bit more later on we're going to
be working in a municipality in colombia
that has been chronically affected by
conflict
82 percent of the participants are
victims of violence
50 to 54 are actually internally
displaced persons
we observe high levels of maternal
mental health with baseline
and we also observed that conflict was
happening at the same time as we were
implementing the program so this creates
uh
challenges for implementing and for
evaluating these programs
and despite these challenges what we see
is in a nutshell very positive results
at an eight-month follow-up
and the four core dimensions that we
intend to uh improve
so we see positive effects of 15
uh
15 standard deviations and an index of
material amount of half
0.23 standard deviations and an index of
child parent relationships and we see
effects of 0.17 and 0.21 standard
deviations
on early child mental health and early
childhood respect so that's pretty much
the summary of what we do
and let me just uh highlight a couple of
contributions from our study
oneness and i've been having as i've
been trying to
um
reinforce throughout this introduction
our program
actually
addresses mature mental health listen
and this is a
totally different approach from that of
other successful parenting interventions
that have been implemented in
non-conference sets
so we know about the very positive
results of the jamaica home visiting
intervention
we know about the
different interventions and and the
evidence from the research program that
actually builds up on the jamaica
program this has been implemented in
different countries in the region it has
also been implemented in colombia both
in rural and urban areas very very
positive results
we also know that this these
interventions uh that are based more on
type of
play-based learning
have been are being currently adapted
for the to respond to syrian refugee
crisis along with the atlanteans program
but again these uh
these programs and these interventions
tackle a different constraint
so if we take a step back maybe we can
think that they tackle informational
constraints on why and how to promote
responsive care and stimulating
environments you have these both group
based and home visiting programs where
a facilitator sits down with the family
to
start playing with the children and
encourage the family to play with the
children so this is very important and
it addresses an important constraint but
again this is a different constraint
than the one that we're trying to uh to
address
we take a step back and we reconsider
explicitly the role of
maternal mental health
and being able to promote this
responsive care and stimulating
and this is actually important there's
actually a few
impact evaluations of early childhood
and progress that are addressing
deficits in mature mental health
there's a recent paper that was
published last year um
in science a review paper of 478 early
child development evaluations and what
they find is that only 12 percent
actually measure maternal mental health
and when they do this it's often to try
to identify dimensions for
heterogeneity
so whether parents uh with better or
worse maternal mental health are
actually
having better worse effects from the
interventions
but what i think this highlights is that
most of these programs are actually not
considering
the role of maternal mental health and
improving these outcomes
the second contribution is that we're
conducting this
program
an experimental evaluation in a setting
of active funds by
2018 there were only five
evaluations being implemented at these
conflict affected settings
mostly in post-conflict settings mostly
in refugee camps
but here we're actually implementing the
program in a setting where conflict is
much alive
where there were struggles by different
armed groups to control the coca drug
trade in colombia and
because of this civilians were severely
victimized at the same time as we were
implementing the program so these are
caregivers that are affected by
displacement by
by unknown conflict and this creates a
lot of challenges to implement and
evaluate these programs and this is
actually going to map in the
experimental design that we're going to
follow and that i'm going to talk about
a little bit later
and perhaps the third contribution is
that we implement the program in a
community based model
the program is delivered by community
members who had no prior experience so
we're going to train them and supervise
them
and this allows us to overcome the
deficits in local capacities and in
professional mental health services that
are characteristics of
countries in the global south in general
and more so in content affected settings
so these three contributions
taking a metronome to health explicitly
in the design of the program
implementing the program in a context of
active conflict and doing so uh
through a community-based model are
going to be the main contributions that
we think actually allow us to observe
the positive effects
that we were
seeing before
so that being said let me skip into
the
uh description of the body okay well the
paper program we
designed the curriculum in 2014 we
tested a pilot in both an implementation
pilot number in 2015
and then we started running the the
impact evaluation in 2018.
so where does the the program comes from
uh it's inspired by the work of our
colleagues alicia lieberman and del mar
at ucsf
alicia had been working for
more than two decades now on what's
called the child parent psychotherapy
this is a clinical intervention
it lasts 37 sessions per year between
the child parent diet
and the trained psychologists in the
clinic
its effectiveness has been demonstrated
by five clinical trials with
mostly latino and afro american
communities right and then when they
realized a little bit of the obstacles
of scaling this up they brought this out
to the community and that's the building
bridges interventions that was led by
the mahrez
2011.
uh so these are
at least the cpp in spirit it's a
through repetitive session to enhance
parents capacity to provide safety and
developmentally appropriate caregiving
it's been implemented in 37 states in
the
also in palestine and israel
and also i think in the nordic countries
yep
you're good
um
the camera's not focused on you
unfortunately okay so one second while
we fix the camera
sorry okay
ah so but if i
[Music]
stand here yes yes if you stand there
that would be great
here yeah better never can you see him
now yes i'm gonna do this from the yeah
okay
i apologize for interrupting no
thank you so much problem welcome
okay and so so again we we
contacted the team at ucsf in 2014 they
had this track record of intervention
and so we adapted the program to the
local context in colombia so what we're
trying to
understand well how do we adapt it to a
context of ongoing conflict
it's different to the needs and the
characteristics of latino communities
that migrated to the us california and
from which the program the original
program actually emerged
uh it's a setting not of
post drugmatic stress
because the complex has not yet
subsided
it's a context of current complex trauma
where the communities and the families
are being constantly exposed to all
these these bad habits these things that
these bad things happening
and it also takes into account what we
know as context depending parenting
styles so for instance uh some
caregivers but might become more
what you can say authoritarian in these
settings
and that's not generally
bad
it's just a response to these kind of
very difficult settings in which it is
right so if something bad is happening
and maybe you just want to you get to
follow your order
as a protective measure right so so we
adapted the program uh
based on these settings in 2015
and how does it work it's a group based
program
uh it's delivered in 15 weekly sessions
so
so participants meet
groups of approximately 15 to 18
participants meet every week
for two and a half hours
here
they meet for two and a half hours
uh assassins are that by two local
facilitators
and the program tries to create first
awareness
on the emotional psychological goal of
conflict
in many of these settings when we come
in to
talk to communities there's
a sort of normalization of what's
happening and how conflict disaffected
and i think it has very important and
evolutionary protective effects
but it also
kind of doesn't allow them to process
how they're affected
how it affects their emotions how their
effects also connect their physical
health
and how it translates into the children
then it tries to create awareness
how do you choose the size of the group
uh so so it's based on the building
bridges
so i don't think they have a good a good
answer
that's the size of the group of the
building bridges so community program
because it seems a big group
fifteen plus the children is 17. so the
children don't vote the children will go
to assessments
the children and i'll tell you in a
second why they don't
um
and so
at first again it tries to create this
awareness about the emotional tools of
conflict
and also tries to create a awareness on
how this affects the relationship of the
children
and how it's directly affecting children
and every time we get to new science
sort of like parents tell us informally
and the group discussions and the focus
groups we we conduct before the people
implementing
that they don't think that their
children are going to be affected
because maybe they were too young
to understand that
their dad had been murdered
or to understand that there were like
shots around like uh gunshots and
confrontations around the name
but actually we know this is totally up
maybe the children are not verbalizing
what's happening
but their behavior
and their brain development is actually
reacting to these different science
so we create awareness on on these
issues
and then the program will trust what the
program tries to do is to
provide some tools so that caregivers
can actually address some of these
issues
so that they can
work on their own mental health
they can work on the child parent
relationship
and how this maps out into
better childhood development and
behavior right and in doing so i think
what the program starts to do is foster
resilience
try to understand and recognize that
these are communities that are affected
by
systematic and pervasive conflict
and that they have within the families
and the communities
the source of resilience and strength
right and so and we create we try to
create the self-efficacy
for the program
so how do sessions work and here i go
back to what i'll do so comment so it's
only the caregivers come to the sessions
and the idea is that they are not coming
in with their children
because otherwise this is gonna take
away the focus from what's happening in
their own emotional world to what's
happening with the children in sessions
oh and i'm gonna show you a couple
pictures here only although the
caregivers that are coming with a
very young
children
[Music]
but they don't have anybody to take for
take care of them while the sessions
they're already allowed to bring them
and so the sessions follow similar
structure
at the beginning there's a warm up and a
stress reduction practice
so sensory awareness they sometimes they
practice some mindfulness exercises some
some salutations like in yoga
then they dig into the main activity and
this is basically a reflective practice
they start understanding and making this
reflection in terms of
in terms of how conflict affects them
how conflict has affected their children
and their relationship
and this is all grounded with art and
crafts to try to ground the information
and then at the end there's a group
discussion
in which the participants then discuss
how they can incorporate this into their
everyday
activities how do you recruit the
participants
uh so i'll tell you in two seconds but
these are these are all families that
participate in the early childhood
centers
right and so the idea is that we're not
trying to put a
higher burden
on these families
asking for women to do more than what
they're already doing
what we try to highlight in this in this
last group discussion is how they can
incorporate
some better and maybe more appropriately
developmental activities into their
everyday activities
and how they can also
start creating these child-rearing teams
how they can start involving the fathers
how they can start involving other
members in the community so that they
can all contribute towards early
childhood
okay so these are these are these are
the sessions actually this is
the one on the left is the is the first
session you can see that some fan some
participants are with their children
there
there's a yarn and there's an activity
in what they start kind of go
throwing a yard between them and we're
trying to create some sort of a
social structure and connectedness in
these settings
uh the one on the right is one of the i
think it's the tenth session
uh you can see there's some arts and
crafts uh here in the ground and they
they're discussing what each of them
actually uh
worked on during the session and again
how they can incorporate this into their
everyday uh settings so that's that's
basically a program and as i mentioned
this is a community lab group
each group is led by two
local facilitators
uh there are facilitators that have no
formal training and psychosocial
programs
in general all of them had some type of
social leadership they had been leading
some type of groups but not in a very
formal structured way
and i think importantly all of them are
community members
all of them are mothers
all of them are exposed to the same
sources of stress and adversity
and actually some of them
have been directly affected by violence
how how we build the local capacities is
through a five-week experiential
training
they go through
the full program
and it's only by them going to the to
the full program that they can then
replicate
and lead to implementation how much
formal education do they typically have
so so
they all at least at the minimum they
they completed a
bachelor's degree um
and so
and some have uh some diplomas in social
work technical clubs and social work uh
some i think one of them is a nurse
and and what this does is it tries to
try to
allows us to overcome deficit to mental
health services right so in the setting
where we're going to operate setting
severely affected by violence there's
only one psychologist
that has been trained to provide some
type of mental health service right
uh
and what we do and i think this is an
important building block of the program
is a weekly reflective supervision
so we have supervisors that meet with
the facilitators
and the supervision is not
focused on
what they need to do next or the
following week
the supervision instead is focused on
the emotional well-being
of these facilitators because it's hard
they're
already trying to understand and process
their emotions and how how this affects
them and now they have to lead these
groups
so it's all they actually meet for a
full day every friday
uh on this reflecting supervision and i
think this this house really allows you
to build these local capacities
so we have two questions from the
audience
so one is that if there is a referral
system available for participants who
are exhibiting severe stress
symptomatology and the other question is
that if uh venezuelan refugees
are in in the staff
so so two two very important questions
thank you so the first one is we do have
a protocol of referrals
uh this protocol is as uh
as we crafted it out for the irb
uh
the pilot like
necessary steps to go through the
local health systems and this is what we
required to do
by law
actually we know that this referral
system actually has a has some obstacles
again because there's no capacity
so what we do is we all have a parallel
system where we do referrals to
different partner organizations that are
working in the field so for instance
heart underlying internationals say the
children have been receiving some of
cases that have
that have
where we see kind of critical cases and
then our supervisors
uh and then the team at ucsf
and our lead psychologist can also come
in to address some of these uh some of
these difficult
circumstances
and the second question venezuelan
refugees this program was originally
created for the space population
then we kind of start open the scope for
communities
generally affected by conflict
and we didn't
realize that by the third cohort of the
program we started receiving
venezuelan venezuelan refugees who
organically kind of took the step and
started participating uh and the in the
next steps of what we're preparing we're
trying to
make up upfront adaptation so that we
can better
address the needs and the currencies of
venezuela
two million venezuelan refugees
okay
so that's now that's the
program then let me tell you about the
impact evaluation first i'm going to
start with a little bit of
of context maybe
many of you know about this
but uh sometimes we lose track of
of the fact that colombia is actually
the country
with the highest number of this
internally displaced persons in the
world
so by the end of
of last year 8.2 million
internal displaced persons in colombia
this is 17 percent of the climate
population
this is
almost 20 of all displaced persons it's
a higher number than what we have in
syria or the drc
maybe we lose track about this crisis
because it's been a protracted conflict
so this is the stock
of displaced person that has been
legally recognized since
early 1990s
but displacement is still happening as i
will show you in a second
and displacement has affected pretty
much
every corner of the country this map
here in the left is showing you the
intensity of displacement
for 100 000 inhabitants across different
municipalities of the country and what
you see is just like the heat map is
totally activated you have some
some spots here this is where
the nearby states are the amazon but
then you see pretty much the whole
country has been affected by
displacement
this is the number of displaced person
since 1997 and 2018.
displacement is still happening despite
the peace agreement with the with the
farc
uh with the parquerella that was signed
in 2016.
conflict is much active there's map on
the right side we took it from uh robert
kaul showing you a heat map
of killings of social leaders
and when you see it's also
uh spread around the country
and we're gonna work on
this place here
which is also one element of society is
more affected by conflict
so this isn't the border with ecuador
and the pacific coast
it's the municipality mostly of african
women population 90 percent of the
colombian population
culturally rich
geographically rich
it's vibrant it's actually a gorgeous
place but it's also being affected by
conflict because
uh
coca leaf crops are grown here
and then this is just like a natural
pathway
for drug trade
and so different our groups have been
always
getting to tomoko to get control
of the drug trade and as a result they
targeted the civilian population to get
this territorial control so we're gonna
work this we're gonna work here
and this is just to highlight
uh that this is a setting of that
these are the homicide rates in tomato
and in colombia what you see is very
stable trend in colombia and what you
see here is the trend
in tomato
what happened here 2012 started with
peace negotiations between the colombian
government and the park ireland
when we started discussing the
possibility of bringing the program to
this place was around here 2016 2017
there was connect
relatively safe conditions
and we were thinking we were coming to a
post-conflict situation
when we started you can see the spike in
homicide rates so homicide rate is four
times higher than in colombia when you
check the intensity of displacement it's
also uh it's 943 versus 2
235 i think so it's also high intensity
of displacement
and
also a very poor
uh context
so what you're seeing here is the map of
poverty rates by block by census block
and in general 45 percent of the
population is considered poor
compared to 20 in colombia
and you can see it's pretty much
widespread across the municipality all
these are rivers where
where the army crews try to get control
of these pathways to ship the drug the
the coca trade out
and
pretty much the only spots that you
don't see here that are
are being activated in terms of poverty
this is an oil plant
this is the airport this is the
connected commercial tourist tourist
beach
other than that
poverty is pretty much widespread
80 percent of the population of the
economically active population are uh
devoted to some informal activity
so pretty vulnerable both in terms of
conflict and both in terms of
socio-economic dimensions
okay
so your question
were the participants these are mothers
in general
um
primary caregivers of young children
shared by early childhood development
centers
these are centers that are that serve
children
around age three to five vulnerable
families
uh this is part of the from zero
national policy from zero to for every
national policy that has been evaluated
uh by many include there's a paper by
uh 2018 i think this is world
development showing
positive effects of the rollout of the
of these centers across the country at
least in terms of language and cognition
uh and our experiment is going to assign
some participants to treatment status
where they have access to the media depe
and in addition to the regular services
that are provided by the centers
and then the control group these are
regular services provided by the centers
right so
how many speed uh
if your family has only uh
less than two years old they're out
if their family has a child challenge
less than three years we we don't find
them because we're coming into the
centers
and that was
that was all a decision we had to make
to try to make it feasible for us to
target the appropriate population and
operate in the same okay
and
we only have so so this is going to be a
a cluster that has we're going to
define the treatment at the cluster
level
and the clusters are in the centers
but we only have 18 centers right so at
least in terms of statistical power it
would have been it would have made more
sense
to randomize individually
but the fact is that we couldn't
and the reason is that
there are invisible borders
across neighborhoods across street that
you cannot cross
so for instance take these two centers
here they're maybe two blocks away
and the community from this center
cannot go to the community with the
center
when we would come in we would have to
come in maybe
go into
a street get the local leader of
that neighborhood he would check us in
we would run the let's say the surveys
if we're running to the other center
we could walk we couldn't walk we had to
go up different local leader had to pick
us up and then bring this in so this
actually prevents us from running the
the evaluation at the individual level
and we had to randomize and we had to
randomize the at the center level
right so
uh we stratify we follow a two-step
approach
first we assign at the center level we
take the ecds we have some data on ecd
size and socioeconomic characteristics
across the front of the centers and then
we randomly assigned to treatment of
control status so we have nine centers
in treatment ninety control
and then we take the
census of the population served by the
census
by the centers
and we randomly assigned participants
over four sequential cohorts
our partner in the field wanted this
program to persist so we took the the
census and we defined okay you're you're
in a treatment center then you can
participate and either afford one two
three or four
right and as uh children we're coming in
later being enrolled later we would add
them to the list and then randomize it
uh in total we have uh 1300 participants
17 700 assigned two
to treatment and 662 to control of
course we were worried about statistical
power
with uh very few clusters
this takes ahead as a function of the
intracluster correlation luckily at
least what we see from admin data and
baseline data is that the ics are pretty
low
these are pretty much centers that serve
very similar pumps very similar
underserved communities
and at least their power calculations at
the beginning we had 80
statistical power to identify effects
between point
22 and point 26 standard deviations
without any controls for oh baseline per
cost here
and these are the two registries over
another
okay
so uh we're gonna
we collected baseline four weeks before
the intervention started
in the treatment group
uh the program ran for 15 weeks
we collected a one-month follow-up then
and we came back and collected a second
funnel for 13 32 weeks eight months
after the program had ended
tonight
to ask a question uh sorry about that um
yeah just to make it interactive and
there are some questions on the chat as
well
um
so i was wondering um
you know you you gave us the
what the
implementation what the program design
looks like
i was just wondering a little bit about
the work that went into it beforehand
which is you know is the science the
psychological science behind this
particular intervention design is it
well settled or is it something that um
you know like who was involved in
designing the program and if somebody
then uh displays any kind of severe
stress symptoms
uh you know should there be some
pharmacological treatment as opposed to
just uh
non
pharmacological treatment like we have
here
and uh there's a related question from
catherine
that is there a referral system
available when participants exhibit
severe stress symptoms
good thank you bushwick again and
because i moved here i'm not seeing the
chat now
where
so
yeah so so oh so you can see me i cannot
i cannot see the chat but but
two very important questions let me
start with the second one so so yeah the
real system we just spoke about this
we have a kind of official referral
system to the public health system
we know that
that system doesn't work there's only
one trained psychologist in the
municipality
that can take into these cases so when
we had uh
critical cases we referred them to
other partner organizations save the
children and
heartland alliance international or the
alliance international runs some
community-led programs in mental health
and we also had our own team of
psychologists that would come in
and would um
and would try to
follow up on these cases uh in practice
we only had
i think six cases
uh out of all seven hundred and
something participants that we followed
through uh these referral protocols
and then i think taking a step back
and then going into your question
when we designed this project so
obviously i'm an economist
i i didn't participate in the
technical design this was led by
a team of psychologists at los angeles
and the team of psychologists at ucsf
and so first we
it took us approximately six months of
uh focus groups and interviews with
victims of conflict
for displaced populations
with
conversations with the national victims
unit which is the
national institution that supports all
victims initiatives we did this in
bogota mainly
and we ran a pilot to test the
the visibility and acceptability of the
program to try to see these
the way in which we approached
the program and the contents is actually
reasonable and well grounded and it's
well received by the population so this
was conducted in 2015 with the support
of the ministry of health in colombia
and the
inter-american development bank then
when we moved to tobacco it's a totally
different setting
uh
and then we ran again uh maybe like a
six-month adaptation into the contents
of the of the program
and the way in which we bring the
program to the community that's where we
decided to
uh run the program through the early
childhood centers because that this
allows us to
find
mothers who have young children and to
come into the neighborhoods
we we're only able to get into the
neighborhoods because we were getting to
the centers
we weren't able to
uh go to the houses and so on and this
is going to matter also for
for the data that we collect
uh so i hope that that answers your
question and maybe and maybe the
the other question i will differ on
whether there's merits or some cases
married from other pharmacological
interventions i think i would defer that
maybe to the psychologists and or deep
saturn
i think that's beyond my uh
my knowledge
and training
okay
so um
so as we mentioned we have four
sequential cohorts
uh we followed the the same
data collection
uh scheduled for each of them
here you have the different dates in
which the data collection uh happened
and as you can see here we're going to
collect
the final
data for three and four and march 2020
and june 2020 and of course the the
pandemic came in right and so
centers
were closed by the end of february
colombia went international lockdown of
march 23rd i think
and so this prevented us from going back
to the field
uh we deployed a quick phone survey
uh in april five to seven weeks after
lockdown started
i think uh we were naive we thought that
maybe by administering a couple
of scales and questionnaires over the
phone we could at least save some
uh key dimensions
that we can use for the full impact
evaluation
but there as soon as we started
analyzing the data we saw that they were
just at high levels of stress anxiety
parenting stress
uh people are already suffering
seventy percent or more loss through
jobs that are into
um so actually we we made an amendment
of the pre-analysis plan right as we
were
running the phone survey and the
eight-month follow-up results are going
to use only the data for which one or
two
and and this is important because
we also specified this in our original
pre-analysis plan
we do not expect that we were not
expected to see any effects on the first
photo
and it's also this is pretty much
consistent with we're informed by the
the clinical trials of the child parent
relationship program where we are
inspired of we were expecting to see the
effects in the second funnel and so of
course we lost half of our sample here
of
you you can't imagine the stress that we
also experience
okay
so we're going to measure
we're going to be focusing on four
uh main dimensions based on the theory
of change of occurring
maternal mental health
child pattern interactions child mental
health early childhood
and we
implemented an administers a set of
batteries
that have been administered in other
programs by other researchers or by
ourselves
that have been translated and validated
in many cases then we know in other
cases have appropriate psychometric uh
characteristics
for the child parent interactions uh so
one of the best strategies in the home
inventory we couldn't do this because we
couldn't go into the neighborhoods we
had to run all the data collection in
the center
so most of these are just uh
self-reports from
from the caregiver who participated in
the program or the control group
and for the child development we have
the
preschool self-readiness assessment at
baseline
and then we go with the administration
of ideala at the first at the second
follow-up
and uh the brief topic of social media
assessment did you see this did where
were the children like the
the small children were with their
parents but where are the other ones
obviously they're at the centers okay so
they're being taken care of so they're
taken care of and the centers provide
uh they dropped them out at around
9 a.m
picked them up at from 3 p.m i think
so the
program was actually implemented around
the schedule the months or the
caregivers
uh usually either after they drop them
out or before they pick them up right
uh children receive the
their food intake is mainly driven by
the centers
right and so this allowed us to have the
participants
fully focused on the program instead of
like figuring out what to do with the
with their kids
um i'm not
i can go into this but uh but maybe for
the sake of time i'll jump just jump and
just mention that uh at least we got
good psychometric properties
so we're gonna use all these scales
and and
bundling them into these composite
indices we do this by gmm
we're going to standardize by the
control group in each wave
and we're going to
put all signs uh we're going to switch
signs depending on the scale so that
positive effects mean improvements
i'm sorry to interrupt i i have a
question given that the focus of the
paper is on mental health and maternal
mental health
um i was wondering if this checklist
doesn't include depression which seems
to be one of the primary constructs
predicting parental investment in
children and one reason why
it's important to treat depression and
women and depression in particular among
all possible constructs
yeah so very good question paula thank
you so so this symptom checklist on er
actually uh provides you data for nine
uh dimensions of mental health anxiety
depression
uh phobic anxiety sensitivity hostility
and three other more
uh we've been using this one because
what we realize in different workers so
at least economists that are starting to
administer these scales usually focus on
depression or focus on anxiety
uh but we're seeing that in many of our
research we pick up
important domains when we check into
other dimensions of mental health
so
so get in the context
and and and the setting of conflict
it's not only about depression
it's also about the sensitivity of these
populations what's happening in the in
the setting
it's also about phobic anxiety which is
clearly tied up to experiences of
displacement and violence
uh so we're able to see this in the
different dimensions
for now at least in the composite
indices we're just going to bundle
everything together and i can show you
results uh in a second uh when we just
um take every measure by itself
but at least uh when we yeah
thank you yeah no thank you for your
question yeah and i get there's
a bracket here that's missing
it's okay but but at least so so
the measures work well we have good
psychometric properties for the indices
uh when we do
internal consistency measures when we do
confirm return factor analysis
so
in general uh for some
we're kind of borderline and so we show
that at least uh our results are robust
if we include or we take out the
these measures okay
okay and some descriptives uh average
participants 29 years old 87 of them are
the mothers we have some grandmothers we
have three or four fathers actually who
decided who came up and participated we
know uh from their anecdotes that were
actually buddied by the community this
is very
uh
patriarchal
strong gender gnomes and so the
community we're actually
making fun of them when they decided to
participate in women's groups
uh child age was
two and a half years at the beginning of
the program in general
uh most of the children connect up
surely that we measure
is actually the second the second
children
82 percent of them direct victims of
violence
exposed to on average 2.3
different violent events
57 of them have been displaced at some
point so just let me show you this
here
this is the distribution of the
direct violent events
and on the right side you see the
maternal mental health anticipation as
you can see let go
it's a very strong uh left so
left and tail that show that highlights
at least
the
sensitivity to conflict
here and uh also very poor
sorry this is not
so so here we're we're comparing the
asset entities for the community in
democracy participants in tobacco with
the acid and expert the nationally
representative population that is
collected by the data
of the yelca a longitudinal survey that
we were administering this and you can
see
just the the distribution into mac was
just
all the way to the left
so we're targeting both we're targeting
the population then we want to talk
okay
and at least on baseline what we see is
that connected the dimensions that we
that motivated this program
the effect of violence and maternal
mental health
and the effect of maternal mental health
on all these other dimensions they show
up at least in basic correlations at
basin
so we see that higher levels of of
violence and baseline are associated
with worse maternal mental health
worse child pain relationships with
early child mental health
what we see is that when there's a
positive
caregiver with mental health this is
actually associated with better outcomes
in the child parent relationships and
what's happening in the church so at
least with the scriptures we see that
that the the fear of changes is
important
uh so
again remember these were 15 sessions
and then we ran the program in four
cohorts
uh based on the
insights of the
partners at ucsf
um
we basically decided that
when somebody participates in at least
six sessions
they kind of graduate from program this
has to be they have to be the first
successes
uh and so you can see that again it goes
only 40 of those that were invited ended
up participating
and this i think has to do with the way
in which we engage in communities at the
beginning it was me talking to
communities about what we wanted to run
then we kind of realized it's better if
actually the local facilitators do this
process and then you can see this this
greater uh engagement
uh on average
we have um that participation was of 11
sessions conditional of participating in
the swim session so when we see connect
the survival analysis what happens is if
they go to the first or second sessions
they pretty much stay
it was just part of the beginning to try
to get some people to participate
okay
and our experiment works well we have
journal validity balance on center
characteristics balance on individual
hassle characteristics uh
we don't find that any of the basic
characteristics are explaining
uh participation in the program and we
did
i think i can say this uh
i think a good job in
terms of reducing attrition only four
percent and ten percent and not
different between the treatment arms
i think this is this is
here's a testament of the survey very
hard because we did a
i think a good job in trying to not lose
track of the populations even though
they were migrating you were so even
though some of them were being displaced
as the problem was happening
okay
so how much time do we have
it's three thirty
three forty five okay so that's nice
so we're gonna follow two empirical
strategies the first one explodes the
random assignment to the treatment of
control arms again by the center level
so we're going to we're going to run lag
dependent variable models
we're going to run one of the composite
indices for each of the dimensions here
on the treatment status on the composite
index at baseline
we're going to control for uh baseline
family and individual characteristics
we're going to control for the cohort
fix effects our baseline controls are
demeaning and interactive with the
treatment
and then we're going to adjust your
cluster standard errors for the small
number of clusters following
gustavsky and tipton
we also do some estimations with a wild
bootstrap and things are pretty
consistent
we're going to adjust for multiple
hypothesis testing using the q anderson
uh
the q andersons and then uh we're also
as a robustness check we're gonna
uh exploit an alternative source of
variation
and this is the variation within
treatment so again remember that we
within the treatment centers we assign
randomly participants to four sequential
cohorts and then it turns out that this
created this phase and design that we
can actually exploit so at the moment
for instance that the cohort one
was uh participating in the first photo
cohort ii was participating in basic so
we can use this
uh to test also the first follow-up
results and we can use this to
test for those second follow-up results
and this
we thought about this when we were
adjusting repeat analysis plan based on
the interruptions from the pandemic
because it allows us to move away from
the clustered assignment so it might
have a little bit more power
and then let me show you the results on
the four main dimensions of the printer
so first in terms of maternal mental
health and i think it's expected we
don't see much
in the in the first photo so in these
tables i'm showing you connect for
transparency what happens when we only
control for the lag dependent variable
what happens when we include chord fixed
effects what happens when we include
controls and what happens with the
treatment of the treated when we
instrument by
uh by the random assignment
um and we can see in
in at the first photo of is just
not only not statistically significant
but pretty much these are almost zeros
right
and then what happens at the egg one
follow up we start picking up these uh
sizeable and statistically significant
effects notice here that we're losing
half of the sample
and this is pretty much because this is
because of the pandemic because we
weren't able to go back
and uh and follow up on these
populations for ports three and four
because of the luck so even though we
have
smaller sample size
and this translates into larger standard
errors
we still see effects of
15 standard deviations under virtual
mental health
dimension
and we see when we actually do the
treatment treated this is actually 0.27
standard deviations
what happens with the child parent
relationships
uh we didn't expect this but we're
picking up
um
statistically significant effects at the
first follow-up
of 0.14 standard deviations on the idt
0.22 standard deviations on the
treatment untreated
what happens at the 81 follow-up
effects are actually
larger even almost twice as large
and much more precise even though again
here we're we're losing precision
because of the
smaller sample size so at the end of the
follow-up are the effects on on the chop
currently it should have scale of
composite ends point 23 standard
deviations on the itt
point 42 standard deviations on the
treatment of the tree
and please interrupt if you want me to
stop by some of these responses
and then what do you think about uh
child dimensions so one is the
child mental health this is measured by
the
child trauma symptom checklist why
not any effects here
at the first follow-up
when we actually think there's uh in the
first photo we don't see much in terms
of mental health early child development
but then again uh you can notice that
the 88 month follow-up
sizeable and statistically significant
effects on child mental health and also
in the early childhood
development domain
right
so
0.17 and 0.21
uh effects of the intent to treat
energy algorithm domains
and then just to so
to test what's happening we do this
within treatment strategy
and what we find here the structure of
these tables is different the first two
columns are showing
first photo ops
the first photo the second two columns
are showing the eight-month photos and
what you can see here is uh pretty much
the same picture as we were getting
and the lag dependent variable model not
much in terms of the effects of the
first follow-up
but then these sizeable effects at the
second part unless uh do you know this
might be an unfair question do you know
the standard deviation of the uh control
group in these variables so we're
standardizing uh
by wave and the control group
so in each
one
it's what
this this implants i mean i know a bit
the stuff of the ect
they're large they're huge they're
larger
but i'm gonna show you that uh that the
sunny city uh they're large
but here they're driven by the
self-reported scale of the moms we don't
see much in the identity
so we see
pretty much a null effect with a lot of
dispersion
when we dig into the sub-dimensions of
the identity we're seeing some things in
terms of social-emotional and executive
functions
but then where we
the next step is what we're discussing
in terms of trying to combine
uh measures from different scales
okay and then and then we do this uh
uh
across the sub dimensions so maybe paulo
was asking this before let me show you
just
that we split up the composite and this
is across the
different sub dimensions this is the
the effect on the
likelihood of being above the risk
thresholds
and here follow for instance so you can
see
depression
anxiety for anxiety sensitivity is
the measurable control so a negative
effect here is it's a positive effect
this reduces the likelihood of being at
risk and so you can see at least in
generals connect these
although all the effects being on the on
the right side but as i was mentioning
here this is the betty
no effect
super impressive
okay
uh and then let me
uh point two of two additional effects
in the ten minutes that we have so one
we're gonna try to do some analysis of
heterogeneity
so at first we had specified that we
were going to use this causal forest of
protocols
uh
we don't find any discernible patterns
and basically this
probably because of statistical power so
these methods require very large samples
we don't have it
uh and actually when we run this the
effects are pretty pretty imprecise and
inconsistent they actually depend on a
lot of the
the seeds that we choose
but then so then we follow like a more
standard method where we split the
sample across key
uh characteristics at baseline
and specifically displacement uh
baseline mental health
and socioeconomic vulnerability
and these are what what we're finding so
so one is in terms of
the differential effects on whether the
person was displaced or not we don't see
much
we don't see that many differences and
and exchanges these are the p-values for
the differences
maybe one a little bit here but they're
too precise
when we see a car according to maternal
mental health below the median
that's where we start picking up some
heterogeneity
so we can see that at the eight month
funnel the effects are larger
for those that had
higher levels of mature mental health
problems so those that were
at risk at tasting that's when we start
seeing like a more positive and stronger
effects and you can see that despite the
despite the small sample these
differences the
statistic is
uh
yes yes
yes
yeah so i'm not reporting
so i should i need to check so the first
we were i need to check here why we're
reporting the p value not the q value
and then we when we check uh also across
socioeconomic vulnerability
we're seeing that it seems
that the effects are being positive for
those that are not extremely poor
so within a very poor environment at
these those that are
uh below the median in that acid index
that i showed you
they are the ones that are
so the ones not below that acidity uh
asset median index they're the ones that
where we start picking up some effects
again at least in mental health that's
where it's a sizable effect so this kind
of takes just a little bit puts it into
a direction sort of all a mars low
hierarchy of of needs
so maybe interesting dimensions when we
think about
uh future programs about
whether this has to be
run
within the early childhood centers where
they where they at least get some type
of social services
and this is going to be important uh and
we were speaking about this
uh earlier uh in terms how do we for
instance
target this program to venezuelan
refugees
so two million refugees that are in
dire circumstances
many of them are not being able to
access conditional cash transfers or
centers so how does it work when you
we're not when you don't have at least
the food
to feed your kids do you have like the
space for this emotional
uh processing growth
but
do you think they would be going to
cities as for us to map i mean probably
they are there yes
they are so they're some of them are
getting to tomoko because it's it's in
the border with ecuador
so some of them as they as they migrate
across the country
they start selecting places where
they're going to
the majority come to big cities but you
start seeing that across rural areas
they're also getting their
uh
okay and maybe the second the second
result that i wanted to highlight is
this is this gonna be the effect
of of the the code pandemic so this is
chords three and four that was the
evolution of bass line
first follow-up we're expecting
something like this based on what was
happening points one and two we weren't
able to measure this we
deployed the phone survey and what you
see is this kind of very strong
and sizeable increase in at-risk
symptoms of anxiety
we see uh four weeks into a pandemic an
increase in fourteen percentage points
and at risk symptoms or anxiety
five percent for five percentage points
for depression ten percentage points for
parent distress
i think
so this was when locked and was
uh which had just gone into lockdown but
then nine months later
11 months later we deployed a second
survey
in november and we see still very
excitable effects for anxiety depression
stress
some preliminary results that i don't
want to stress that much
we do see that at the
november
2020 follow-up phone survey uh it seems
that the treatment helped mitigating
some of these some of these effects
and first paper was actually so the
paper analyzing the the effects on the
first photo was published last year
at the atlantic global house so
five minutes left and let me just wrap
up
again
i think what we try to innovate here is
to address and i think it's motivated by
the
the effects of conflict on maternal
mental health
and how actually this is important by
itself
but also important because it affects
the capacity of these caregivers to
prevent promote provide these
stimulating
and developing developmentally
appropriate
uh settings for the children
uh i think the
innovation also is
implementing this through the community
yeah i i just sorry though
before you go
month into time
uh slightly this is very interesting
but one thing that was perplexed is why
did you
decide to go to the
and what i remind you is that for
instance
if you were to use i don't know to micro
at all so it might be not visible there
but if you go to the family
the families the and you could do that
organization across families
because
already they have meetings in groups
it seems to me a very natural
environment where you try to do that
kind of
expansion
the families the family mothers are
typically local women
you know implemented in their context
they will get a much
larger sample size probably
uh and uh a student family asked for
zero to two
and lots of these ladies in any care
first of all they is a good time to do
the intervention and they might have all
the children given that your focus is on
the mothers
so so
you know maybe there are no families in
my poor
so to be honest i'm not sure if they
have families
i
have never heard
about the program operating uh as we
were running the the intervention
so the focus on the c and the on the
sides was
basically
because we partnered up with uh
an organization in the field called
genesis foundation
which was for operators for the
for the early childhood centers
and so so they yell out okay so come in
and
and you can and you can run the program
here but i think i think your comment is
very very important as we're now trying
to figure out how to scale
you should never chat with the
uh
because families
is aware
so i to me see mr mo because you already
have groups like it's actually smaller
than 15. there was by uh i
i asked the question at the beginning
it's like nine or ten
and the children go there
because they're really small
too
so that's that's very good comment thank
you
and i think it helps us so now
and just to wrap up maybe oh so again
i discussed this at length this
implementation in the context of ongoing
conflict
of a complex current
trauma
and uh and i think though
like in general the results speak both
to the need
we need to think hard about these
programs we need to bring them in we
need to
evaluate them but also that it's not
only needed but also feasible
right and when we think about cost
effectiveness or scalability
uh cost per participant was 435
the nearest program for the ece
they were running a
program
called mi
familia they were starting to design it
before the pandemic the program per
participant was six hundred dollars this
is per year per year per yeah per
participant of those three
and then uh linear cbt just
not comparable but then your cvt program
is six thousand dollars right so so we
can do this and we can do this uh
uh
properly
um
i think a reasonable cost right and so
right now we're working on what we call
at scale pilot we're handing in the
operation to um
to an external partner actually cardinal
alliance which was if you remember the
organization in tomoko that provided
some
mental health chronicles
we're moving towards five minutes of
panities
in the caribbean coasts
and the pacific region
uh different populations in the
caribbean coast
which have high influx of venezuelan
refugees
so we're already starting to adapt
the implementation there and there's an
ongoing conversation to enhance the
model with some play-based activities
and again i mentioned at the beginning
we're trying to address a different
different
restriction but of course this doesn't
mean that the restrictions that other
programs are trying to address are not
there
so how can we how can we complement
these strategies and we're working with
sesame worship
to try to complement maybe have some
activities for the children
uh and for he for this part we're using
uh we're gonna be using an
implementation science
evaluation framework so mostly focusing
on the processes and not on the inputs
we're gonna do a pre-post
follow-up but
not a proper impeccable image
and i think that's uh
that's it
so i think right on time maybe i i went
for one more minute
and so thank you
again for the for the time and for the
opportunity to present here uh your
comments and i don't know if there's
something in the chat
no there are no more questions in the
chat
so
i don't know if uh the
audience in soon would like to ask uh
some questions
um
somebody wants to follow
so i saw in in at the beginning of the
talk and at the end of the talk as well
that fifty percent of your sample were
idps so i assume that everyone else was
more or less considered to be part of
the host
community so i guess out of curiosity
um i wanted to ask you if you observe
differences in the type of trauma and
violence that these two populations have
experienced
and if you do observe differences
whether
i would be surprised that there are no
heterogeneous effects along that
dimension and i think it would be an
important point for the paper to say
regardless of the type of exposure to
violence that these populations
experience which to me could be either
betrayal trauma in the form of ipv or
you know exposure to conflict the fact
that the intervention works regardless
of the type of trauma that these women
are exposed to could be an interesting
angle to emphasize in this data
okay yeah uh so so thank you i think
that's a great comment so one
my perception is that
we're not picking up so my
intuition was that we were going to be
picking up
heterogeneity across the idp dimensions
we don't but i think
maybe there's a chance that this is just
basically because of lack of sample
power right so in general you need
connect 16
times to like a larger sample to be
picking up some
some heterogeneity in some of these
dimensions and that's i think where your
comment don't ask you one on adjusting
for multiply but this testing comes in
uh neatly so
so that's part of the part of the story
the second part we haven't tested
or analyzed the data in this dimension
that you mentioned in terms of
differences and exposure to violence
or trauma among the space and
non-displaced persons these are general
communities that are some of them have
been displaced
within the old municipality
from different neighborhoods as
different our youth get to a
neighborhood the community has to move
away they're pretty much integrated in
the communities we don't have this place
camps in colombia
the displays arrive and they're pretty
much the same culture everything is the
same and they they settle in outskirts
of the cities and tomorrow's pretty much
the same neighborhood so at least when
you
when you when you talk to people you
don't see any kind of main differences
but we can think about uh analyzing the
data also in the way that you propose
and i think your comment in terms of
like
if this works for these two clinical
dimensions that's that's a good point to
emphasize thank you so much for that
comment
so if you join me thank you and this for
the presentation and any
extra questions you can send an email
one day so thank you very much everybody
thank you so much